hot breath let me tell you something i
did two that didn't get bought
oh okay bro my first two did not get
bought by anybody
i got one called uh breaking out the
park and one called urban legend
that i was selling as dvds on the road
and nobody bought them and i think
i think breaking out the park is one of
my best specials
out there just i didn't have a big
enough name i didn't have the right
representation but
networks and they didn't really know who
i was at the time even though i
hosted comic view they didn't really
know but
um now it's crazy i've
ended up selling both of them 10 years
and 15 years after i recorded them i
ended up stumbling
to like different studios that gets it
out on itunes and
everywhere else so i ended you know it
took me years but i sold it but
the first two mine didn't sell but it
didn't discourage me
i was like all right one i got sick of
doing the material
and i wanted to do new materials i was
like let me put a special together
and we just we shot it hired the camera
guys paid everybody i owned all the
rights to it
and then that's all i did because i
wasn't getting
nobody was like calling me to shoot to
uh
we want to do your special and pay you
for it so i was like well i'll just
shoot it myself and
hopefully i'll sell it and luckily um
the true story i didn't do by myself
code black did it
but that sold the show time so that
helped my relationship with showtime it
did good on there
so the next one i just did myself and
everybody passed but show time
it shows i was like oh okay we remember
your last one even though i didn't do
that one
that's how i've sold my last three to
show time they were like i did it myself
but they're like oh okay
he does good numbers and you know
you know just it works out yeah there's
several people in the chat
saying they're going to buy it right now
they're going to buy both right now they
said
so breaking out the park is probably
i think we shot that in 2001 mm-hmm i
look like a little kid in there
this is why i remember when we shot it
because
literally the we shot at draft weekend
and
san diego was supposed to pick michael
vick it's weird how you remember things
and they traded the pick
in atlanta michael vick and san diego
got ladainian tomlinson
and for some reason i was in san diego
that weekend
shooting that special and i just
remember that was the big news in the
area like damn we're supposed to get
michael vick
[Laughter]
that's how long gold was well this
yeah this was definitely a moment in
this show in my career i won't forget so
i i appreciate you taking the time to do
this gary i
i realized we ran a few minutes over but
thanks for seriously doing this
um we're always in this with like just
closing advice
for comics something you've picked up
through your career advice you'll never
forget something you can kind of end us
with here
you're never as funny as your best set
and you're never as bad as your worst
set
i'll leave it at that don't get too
depressed but also don't get too cocky
awesome and how much did that special
cost break out
breaking out of the park self-produced
do you remember
um here's the thing i got
i had my tv deal with quincy jones and i
took that money and shot my special
i think that special end up running me
about fifty five
thousand dollars okay and i made i
remember i made like
twenty three thousand dollars back at
the door that night because i had bought
the theater too
so i was like with thirty i'm i was like
thirty some thousand dollars in the hole
after it was all said and done and then
i went shopping it
and nobody bought it and that was a
little disappointing
but then i boxed it started selling on
the road for 20 dollars
so it might have taken me two years but
i made the money back so
awesome i'll mark five and then i end up
getting
you know i end up buying it somebody end
up buying it
for more money than what i paid to make
it granted
15 years later 16 years later but it
ended up
working out because i had it and i owned
it